[Musique]
la lwin a toujours été une journée bien
spéciale pour le riz pronovost patatras
maquiller depuis l'âge de 7 ans elle
profite de cette fête pour laisser aller
son imagination en transformant ses
clients en de véritables personnages
fantastiques
j'ai tout un trip est selon lui de plus
je te dis ça j'ai eu mal et j'ai
commencé à faire des bonds maquillage
puis ça a comme tout le temps était à
s'améliorer à 1 face à me donner tout le
temps un goût dans canal plus qui je me
soumets à faire des recherches puis j'ai
jamais arrêté ce plat tu fais que c'est
une passion j'aime les films d'horreur
aussi que je fais j'ai fait une
exposition de toiles d'horreur si ça
vient tout avec tueur
au fil des ans l'artiste a développé ses
propres techniques sans formation au
maquillage
l'autodidacte a appris les rudiments du
métier avec des photos et des vidéos
c'est paraissent alors écoute totalement
hypothéqué butin puis des fans sommet de
son art et regarder des vidéos et des
terres des vestiaires des erreurs c'est
vraiment l'apprentissage de vin étant
donné l'investissement groupe d'énergie
plus d'argent dans cette passion le ses
créations connaissent beaucoup de succès
elles lui ont valu de nombreux prix
régionaux au cours des dernières années
c'est des concours c'est sûr je continue
à participer aux cinq épices aussi
renouveler à chaque année et puis on
commence déjà avec magie mais depuis mon
conjoint de parler des projets prochain
projet puis c'est sûr doit participer à
toutes ces années si je me fais demander
des contrôles dans l'année bien que ne
vivent pas de sa passion la plus grande
satisfaction de l'artiste et de
transporter ses toiles vivantes dans son
univers ici je suis cabec banderas du
canada 5 elisabeth de coûts